offenbar doch eine terrortat der mann
der vorgestern in paris vier polizisten
tötete war islam ist der fall bringt
innenminister castanea in bedrängnis
streit um die seenotrettung selbst in
der eigenen fraktion stoßen die pläne
von innenminister seehofer auf kritik
die rückkehr des königs nach seinem
triumph in doha wird
zehnkampf-weltmeister niclas kohl in
seiner heimat gefeiert
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen zu
unserem nachrichtenüberblick am samstag
mit viel sport und polizei
hallo guten abend der fall der tödlichen
messerattacke im pariser
polizeipräsidium nimmt eine neue wendung
am nachmittag gab die staatsanwaltschaft
einzelheiten zum täter bekannt danach
stand der mann der vorgestern eine
kollegin und drei kollegen erstochen
hatte seit längerem in kontakt zu
islamisten
das hat der innenminister kassen er am
donnerstag nicht erwähnt weshalb er
jetzt in erklärungsnot gerät aus paris
thomas walde die staatsanwaltschaft für
terror fälle wertet ihr das telefon des
polizei- mitarbeiters aus der vier
kollegen tötete
kurz vor den morden habe der täter 33
textnachrichten mit seiner frau
ausgetauscht
die nachrichten hatten ausschließlich
religiösen inhalt sie schlossen ab mit
zwei ausdrücken allahu akhbar und folge
unserem geliebten propheten mohammed und
studiere den koran mit extremer gewalt
so der staatsanwalt habe der
polizeimitarbeiter am donnerstag seine
kollegen angegriffen bevor er selbst
getötet wurde
der mann soll in der vergangenheit
kontakt mit salafisten gehabt und auch
das attentat auf charlie hebdo
gutgeheissen haben
der innenminister hatte zunächst nicht
auf ein mögliches terroristisches motiv
hin risikoniveaus ja der mann war seit
vielen jahren in der abteilung zur
nachrichten verarbeitung bekannt wo er
mit seinen kollegen zusammen arbeitete
ohne auffälligkeiten in seinem verhalten
ergab niemals anlass zur besorgnis
diese aussage ist nun umstritten
oppositions abgeordnete fordern einen
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
und den rücktritt es ist nötig dass der
innenminister ersetzt wird es geht um
die sicherheit der franzosen
die behörden kündigten heute weitere
ermittlungen an aber der fall ist schon
jetzt eine schwere belastung für die
pariser polizei und für die regierung am
dienstag beraten die innenminister der
eu über einen neuen plan zur verteilung
von bootsflüchtlingen ausgearbeitet von
deutschland frankreich italien
und malta in der hoffnung dass sich noch
andere länder anschließen
auch seehofer hatte ja angekündigt
deutschland wolle jeden vierten aus
seenot geretteten aufnehmen
darüber ist nun in der union eine
debatte entbrannt wie patricia
wiedemeier berichtet der innenminister
reist durch europa wirbt in der türkei
und den griechenland für eine gemeinsame
europäische asylpolitik sagt hilfe zu
denn die zahl der flüchtlinge sie steigt
dramatisch an wenn wir ihnen nicht
helfen das möchte ich der bevölkerung in
deutschland sagen dann ist es nur eine
frage der zeit bis waren diese
flüchtlinge auch in deutschland sind
doch nach seehofers besuch gestern ist
heute nun eine heftige debatte über
einen seiner vorschläge entbrannt wonach
deutschland pauschal 25 prozent der
geretteten bootsflüchtlinge aufnehmen
könne
wenn andere eu staaten freiwillig
mitmachen die rückendeckung der
regierung soll seehofer dafür haben
nicht jedoch die der eigenen fraktion
der vorsitzende brinkhaus reagierte
heute sehr zurückhaltend zitat wir
dürfen schlepperorganisationen nicht
ermutigen mehr zu machen das war eine
initiative des innenministers nicht der
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
es gibt es auch bei der opposition ich
denke der weg den seehofer einschlägt
ist der falsche er sendet ein signal für
mehr migration aufnahme garantien sind
anreizsysteme zu kommen wir brauchen in
europa breite mehrheiten für die
beschlüsse wenn herr seehofer aber nicht
mal seinen eigenen fraktionsvorsitzenden
überzeugt dann bin ich skeptisch ob ihm
dies auch mit den chefs anderer staaten
gelingen wird es ist wichtig dass der
innenminister jetzt auf europäischer
ebene klar macht dass es wirklich um
eine gemeinsame europäische lösung geht
um solidarität und dass deutschland auch
aus den vergangenen jahren gelernt hat
die diskussion über die
flüchtlingspolitik sie ist neu entbrannt
und wird wohl weitergehen dass die
vereinbarung wieder ausgesetzt werden
kann sollte die anzahl der schlepper
boote stark ansteigen fand heute
übrigens kaum beachtung
seit tagen protestieren die menschen im
irak gegen die regierung gegen
misswirtschaft und korruption
mit äußerster brutalität gehen die
sicherheitskräfte gegen die
demonstranten vor vorläufige bilanz
mehr als 90 tote und fast 4000 verletzt
das meldet die staatliche
menschenrechtskommission um die
situation zu beruhigen hob die regierung
eine ausgangssperre wieder auf
inzwischen soll es gespräche zwischen
demonstranten und parlaments
abgeordneten gegeben haben
was genau wurde gesagt in jenem heiklen
telefonat zwischen us präsident tram und
seinem ukrainischen kollegen sie lenski
drei vorsitzende von
untersuchungsausschüssen haben jetzt die
ganz große keule heraus geholt unter
strafandrohung verlangen sie vom weißen
haus die herausgabe aller dokumente aus
vor schenkten britta jäger die stehe
nach wie vor voll hinter ihm das
gipfeltreffen seiner jungen schwarzen
wählerschaft im weißen haus ist wie
balsam für die tramps sehne er scheint
der einzige präsident sie sein der im
amt jünger wird trump beinahe verlegen
dann setzt er wieder zum angriff an
gegen die medien vor allem aber die
oppositionellen demokraten
sie versuchen euch die wahlentscheidung
zu nehmen die versuchen eure stimme und
euer land zu stehlen aber sie haben
nicht was sie dafür brauchen
doch die demokraten machen weiter druck
in einem brief an trumps stabschef
moreni drohen sie nun mit strafe sollte
das weiße haus angeforderte unterlagen
zu trumps ukraine politik nicht
herausgeben
auch von vize präsident mike pence
fordern sie gesprächsprotokolle und
e-mails deadline mitte oktober
es wird immer enger für den präsidenten
trotzdem sieht er sich nach wie vor am
längeren hebel über eine amtsenthebung
entscheidet am ende der senat den
dominierend rams republikaner und bei
denen betont er immer wieder sei er
immer noch sehr beliebt
der einflussreiche republikanische
senator romney allerdings nennt trumps
unverschämte und beispiellose anfrage
nach ermittlungen gegen joe biden falsch
und katastrophal
trump twitter zurück mitt romney wusste
nie wie man gewinnt er ist ein
aufgeblasener arsch trump setzt weiter
auf verbalattacken solange sich die
öffentliche meinung nicht deutlich gegen
ihn richtet kann er den kampf gewinnen
in hongkong gilt seit mitternacht ein
vermummungsverbot dennoch ging heute
wieder hunderte menschen mit
gesichtsmasken auf die straße um gegen
die eigene regierung zu demonstrieren
außerdem fürchten sie einen wachsenden
einfluss chinas aus sorge vor weiterer
gewalt wurden u-bahn-stationen gesperrt
und der schienenverkehr ausgesetzt
auch viele geschäfte blieben geschlossen
deutschland ist spitzenreiter
klingt gut gilt aber für etwas
ökologisch bedenklich ist nämlich für
den immensen pro-kopf-verbrauch von
papier und pappe keins der 20
wichtigsten industrie und
schwellenländer verbrauchen so viel wie
deutschland jeder von uns kommt im
schnitt auf rund 241 kilogramm
erst dahinter die usa mit knapp 211 und
japan über die ursachen berichtet luton
leinhos die papierlose gesellschaft von
wegen in internetseiten lesen wir zwar
mehr am bildschirm und drucken weniger
aus doch beim papierverbrauch tut sich
am ende wenig 1990 lag der bei 188
kilogramm je einwohner
2006 der maximalwert seither ist er
stabil liegt bei nun 241 kilogramm
einiges ist ins netz abgewandert und es
fällt weniger papier so bei zeitungen
und büroarbeiten
hier nimmt der pro kopf verbrauch seit
2007 kontinuierlich ab und liegt heute
sogar wieder unter dem wert von 1990 dem
netz sei dank nicht ganz denn im
internet kaufen immer mehr verbraucher
auch ein online verpackungen haben sich
in nur zehn jahren versechsfacht von
120.000 auf fast 770.000 tonnen
das liegt auch daran dass die online
händler verstärkt auf das produkt papier
karton und pappe setzen und weniger auf
plastik außerdem wird inzwischen mehr
wiederverwertet der altpapier anteil in
der deutschen papierindustrie hat seit
1990 von 49 prozent auf mittlerweile 76
prozent zugenommen
portugal wählt morgen ein neues
parlament knapp elf millionen menschen
dürfen ihre stimme abgeben
in einem land das nach der finanzkrise
erst wieder auf die beine kommen musste
2011 wurde portugal mit vielen eu
milliarden vor dem bankrott gerettet
jahre harte sparpolitik folgten
doch die sind inzwischen vorbei und
obwohl die staatsverschuldung immer noch
hoch ist geht premierminister costa mit
seiner sozialistischen partei als klarer
favorit ins rennen
denn seine regierung setzt auf
investitionen und das mit erfolg
antonio musste seine wohnung in lissabon
räumen ein investor will sie in eine
ferienwohnung umwandeln doch melo hatte
glück im unglück
die stadt hat diese günstigen wohnungen
auf den markt gebracht zuerst 14 später
noch mal 44 und ich habe
glücklicherweise eine bekommen
die regierung will mehr öffentliche
wohnungen anbieten das ziel bezahlbare
mieten auch für arme menschen
der sozialist antonio costa wie es in
den letzten tagen des wahlkampfs darauf
hin dass die wirtschaft des landes
wachsen
portugal habe die finanzkrise überwunden
die sozialistische partei hat die
sparpolitik beendet wir haben den
portugiesen die alltagssorgen genommen
sie müssen keine angst mehr haben vor
lohn und rentenkürzungen oder
steuererhöhungen touristen bringen geld
ins land nachdem es anderswo terror
anschläge gab die regierung nutzt den
spielraum senkt steuern für investoren
lissabon ist sitz zahlreicher startups
nach der finanzkrise haben junge
menschen portugal verlassen jetzt kehren
sie zurück die arbeitslosenquote
halbiert es gibt mehr stellen für
programmierer als programmierer selbst
ich habe eine reihe von angeboten
abgewogen bevor ich mich entschieden
habe
die regierung macht politik für die
schwächsten und für investoren die wahl
in portugal wird so zum referendum über
die reformen der linken
du bist was du isst galt früher gilt
auch noch heute und so kann man auf dem
teller gut sehen wie sich unsere
gesellschaft verändert hat aktuell auf
der hundertsten anuga in köln der
weltgrößten messe der
ernährungsindustrie aussteller zeigen
was im trend liegt und damit bald auch
im supermarktregal alle möglichen
alternativen zum fleisch etwa was war
was sich geändert hat und was kommt
zeigt dominik müller sl heuschrecke
pikant oder mehlwurm leicht gesalzen
noch ein nischen snack doch wer weiß
vielleicht ja die kulinarische zukunft
wenn man es schafft die berührungsängste
abzubauen
die lachen sich ja schon
auch verarbeitet im müsli riegeln mit
schokolade umhüllt oder als burger essen
aus insekten ist vielfältig und
proteinreiche und weil die insekten
aufzucht viel weniger wasser und
ressourcen verbraucht als die
herstellung von fleisch etwa könnten
insekten eine interessante alternative
sein
was im jahr 2019 mal alles auf dem
teller landen wird hätte man sich nicht
träumen lassen auf der anuga im lauf der
jahrzehnte drehte sich in der
gutbürgerlichen küche doch alles im
fleisch und wurstwaren
es schmeckte wenn es möglichst deftig
war
essen als spiegel der zeit heute liegen
fleischalternativen den trend
vegetarische und vegane die sich dabei
in aussehen und geschmack fleisch immer
weiter angenähert haben die kunden
interessieren sich immer stärker für
solche fleisch ersatzprodukte weil sie
natürlich auch die debatte um
nachhaltigkeit und klimawandel um den
einfluss der konventionellen tierhaltung
auf den klimawandel mitbekommen und
insofern sich auf fragen können wir
durch unser eigenes einkaufsverhalten
dazu etwas beitragen wobei auch
richtiges fleisch natürlich nach wie vor
gegessen wird vor allem die insekten
alternativen sind nicht jedermanns sache
großer bahnhof heute für den neuen könig
der leichtathleten wurde genau
herzlicher empfangen niklas kaul der
neue zehnkampf weltmeister ist zurück in
deutschland
am mittag wurde er am frankfurter
flughafen von zahlreichen fans empfangen
der 21 jährige mainzer hatte in doha
überraschend den titel gewonnen als
jüngster zehnkämpfer der geschichte es
kommt was auf ihn zu freunde familie
empfänge termine der müde könig der
athleten wird nach wenig schlaf zuletzt
schon bald die stressigen folgen seines
ruhms zu spüren bekommen
freu mich da auf jeden fall drauf und
muss aber gucken dass ich das auch
abstimmen kann dann wenn ich wieder
anfangen mit dem training und vor allen
dingen auch nächste woche wieder
anfangen mit der uni das dass das nicht
negativ beeinflusst weil ich glaube das
ist ganz ganz wichtig jetzt den weg
einfach auch weiter zu gehen nach nach
tokio und sich jetzt nicht auf dem
erfolg auszuruhen den eintrag ins
goldene buch seiner heimatstadt mainz
hat er dann auch noch absolviert der tag
der heimkehr gleich schon wieder so was
wie ein kleiner mehrkampf einer geht
noch heute abend ist er gast bei uns im
aktuellen sportstudio von 23 uhr 30 an
zusammen mit freiburgs kapitän christian
günther
platz vier gestern in der hitze der
nacht für den geher christopher linke
beim sieg des japaners jammer schnitt
lag er auf der 20 kilometer distanzen
und 19 sekunden hinter dem bronzerang
heute qualifizierten sich drei dlv
athleten für die finalkämpfe von morgen
locker und selbstbewusst wird mariah
carey hamburg deutschlands beste
weitspringerin die qualifikation am
abend für sie eine angenehme
pflichtaufgabe erster versuch einen
sicherheits sprung sie verschenkt gut 20
zentimeter dennoch sechs meter 98 sie
bleibt die favoritin für das finale
morgen abend genau wie johannes vetter
im speerwerfen der zweite der
weltrangliste überzeugt mit dem
weitesten wurf in der qualifikation 89
meter 35
auch julian weber steht im finale
überraschend ausgeschieden hingegen der
olympiasieger thomas röhler und
teamkollege andreas hofmann
morgen läuft bei uns im zdf die
leichtathletik die deutschen turnerinnen
haben bei der wm in stuttgart mit der
qualifikation für olympia ihr
minimalziel erreicht dass wir im team
finale allerdings ist fast sicher außer
reichweite momentan platz acht der wird
vermutlich nicht reichen denn heute
abend sind die starken usa noch am start
überraschung in der fußball bundesliga
bayern münchen kassierte die erste
niederlage in der laufenden saison die
samstags ergebnisse vom siebten spieltag
vier tage nach dem 7 2 bei tottenham in
der champions league verliert bayern
münchen 1 2 gegen hoffenheim leverkusen
leipzig 11 freiburg erkämpft sich ein 2
2 gegen vize meister dortmund
aufsteiger paderborn gegen mainz 1 2
das abendspiel schalke gegen köln bei
uns im sportstudio gestern härter gegen
düsseldorf drei zu eins in der tabelle
rückt die spitzengruppe noch enger
zusammen bayern leipzig freiburg
leverkusen jetzt punktgleich schalke
kann am abend noch tabellenführer werden
die zweite hälfte beginnt mit hertha
mainz verbessert sich um drei plätze auf
13 paderborn bleibt letzter ja und
deutschlands fußball frauen stürmen
weiter richtung europameisterschaft
dritter sieg im dritten
qualifikationsspiel einen monat nach dem
8 0 im hinspiel gewinnt der
rekord-europameister auch die zweite
partie gegen die ukraine mit
zu null drei treffer im aachener tivoli
erzielte lina magull ebenso wie die erst
18 jährige klara ein torfestival nennt
man so kann es weitergehen
die das wetter zeigt sich am sonntag im
nordosten freundlich im südwesten
dagegen ziemlich verregnet mehr dazu
gleich mit christa stieg das war es von
uns das heute journal mit marietta
slomka um 23 uhr 15
und wir sind morgen wieder zur stelle
wegen der leichtathletik-wm etwas früher
um 18 uhr 45
einen schönen samstagabend noch tschüss
[Musik]
gegen abend einfach herzlich
wechselhafte und teils regnerische tage
stehen uns bevor
schon heute nacht gehört der sprühregen
über dem erzgebirge und den alpen zu
einem abziehenden tief also der lässt
nach aber aus dem südwesten kommt schon
wieder ein neues tief mit regenwolken
morgens bis zum rhein voran
auch über der ostsee gibt es ein paar
schauer dazwischen ist es teils neblig
teils klart es auf und das vor allem in
der osthälfte und dann wird es kalt weil
nur 0 bis 3 grad und frostgefahr
unter den wolken im südwesten bleibt es
bei sechs bis neun grad und genau diese
wolken schieben sich dann morgen über
das land voran sogar bis zum emsland und
zum erzgebirge und richtig verregnet ist
es dann schon vormittags von nordrhein
westfalen bis nach baden württemberg und
nachmittags auch in bayern und das kann
kräftiger regen seien mit um 20
millimeter ein paar schauer sind auch an
der ostsee möglich insgesamt ist es im
nordosten aber ganz anders morgen da
scheint sogar fünf bis neun stunden die
sonne dann ist es einfach freundlich
zwischen brandenburg und der nordsee die
temperaturen dazu liegen zwischen 7 und
16 grad und auch die ganze neue woche
ist auf ähnlichem temperaturniveau am
montag gibt es dafür einen trockenen
sonne wolken mix dagegen am dienstag es
fast überall teils kräftig regnet auf
wiedersehen